so do you want to make the move or
should I that was so close like ten
percent down stairs really quick and I
woke my cat up and brought her up here
and she looks really confused thank you
thank you for moving they'll never
notice me no really who's on my team
alright the guy we got me in Jordan whoa
you ever does the end of the map is that
it I guess it is what the [ __ ] they're
hiding somewhere they gotta be okay oh
[ __ ] Oh lots of chairs okay no no I just
got one more intense they could be one
of the duplicate No slam [ __ ] around
basically it's good yeah yeah
hmm are you a toilet yeah a piece of poo
in the toilet oh my god okay walking
right by him [ __ ] this room holy crap
[Music]
[Laughter]
is one of the shelves behind you what's
going on here I'm [ __ ] with you and
he's like nowhere near there I wish I
was that good of an actor but this is no
idea yeah
it's mark still in the same spot are you
still in the same real mark
I don't good Jeff I have not moved since
the beginning of the game I am not lying
computer in the stay in the corner the
white computer in the corner in the
corner right there in the corner like he
could walk it you're looking right at
him where are you blue shelf a gigantic
blue shelf come out of that weird come
out of the room you walked by me so many
times I give you here the chair ones no
one is using my strategy which I want to
make sure in case that's the just in
case I'm lying yes uh-huh at the table
well we only had 30 seconds left so I
had to I had to do something god damn it
again okay
[Music]
again and I'll do this again I haven't
moved since the beginning I have not
I mean that could mean a lot of things
though yeah I'm in the exact same spot
now marks doing a really good job so you
guys will probably be really embarrassed
good job why would be why would we be
embarrassed you guys feel like you're
your hunting skills are inferior 'z what
I'm trying but if he's doing such a good
job of probably work on you too
so cinderblock right here yep no oh yeah
what's clean it's clean oh no something
just happened nope he said oh no he said
I don't know you're what gives him here
he's in here not that worries not even
now trickiness
he has a strategy that is far different
than everyone else's you gotta think
like mr. Hulk
almost you guys no no no no no no no
warmer warmer warmer warmer
are you it so hot good for you
God thank you
a very mistaken
making Masseria okay hmm I was well I
was well nothing to worry about seemed
out of the run to me no I'm pretty sure
this is going to end
we're not dying but it was leg off to
the side I don't know I you know what to
do Nick I don't know what you're talking
about what it won't be like yeah
thoroughly boned everything including
maybe they won't notice okay now we go
moving now what did you do okay all
right guys you what the zombies this
yeah yeah they're gonna get in sorry Oh
God is this working
mighty newbie homework what happened to
me Jess why are you shooting your desk
you need that for homework
okay really the worst of Gregg I'm
finally in a good spot really where the
zombies will find me
well these doors are of it but really
you were looking around when I aimed at
you what were you what were you posing
else I was a plank of wood mm okay
stop it just happened there what I'm so
[ __ ] confused
[Laughter]
it wasn't a newspaper did it a little
bit more please wait oh here we go are
you sure you're shooting the right one I
don't know what to do man I just think
forever
Oh God like your bottle totally confuses
us every time it's rewarding oh man your
model tricks oh good times
man whoo all right back to work so uh
how about the zombie invasion eh it's
kind of carried crazy here caps could do
this just be careful the entire the
entire thing that I did was just a decoy
actually yeah you know he's not wrong
heck you just own to my parents the only
thing is I don't have this house is
clean I want to find you now yeah okay
all right here's they get a little more
obvious where the zombies walk is where
I not be never what a hint are you
somewhere we can get through or no yes
oh my god oh my god I'm so in plain
sight I'm so in plain sight this is
probably the most overt location that's
ever been located
yeah all right to choose the things that
nobody select
how it works I ain't no genius when it
comes to kitchen sinks but this don't
look right okay
[Laughter]
like seriously I'm not saying a word I I
am where my friends died I am so in the
open you guys do not know how open it is
[Laughter]
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
Wow
I'm in a crowd